when we were doing that we were still
like dropping the lyrical [ __ ] but this
new [ __ ] is like it's more dysfunctional
you know how many uh well first of all
you got the name of the project yeah
breaking point two so it's not yeah
because I did a mixtape a couple years
ago with DJ Green Lantern and
Billionaire Boys Club called breaking
point it was a couple of years ago maybe
longer I mean my concept of time is
[ __ ]
wait when was the first Green Lantern
tape you did maybe 10 years ago
it might have been 10 years ago okay
wait wait wait 2011 2012. so that's the
same one that's the the sequel yeah it
took a while okay I just want to make
sure I'm not crazy this is like a
Terminator pretty sure that was like 11
years ago this is like Avatar Avatar too
it might have been 12 years ago I think
it was 2011. so 11 12 yeah yeah I think
it's more 2011. maybe yeah yeah I don't
know you probably know better than I do
I think it was 2010. 2010 I'm going to
look it up we should look it up let's
look it up we have these [ __ ] million
dollar devices in our hands I'm in I'm
in I'm because I'm trying to remember
when I first
I feel like I was working at Power I
don't know yeah you might have been uh
might have been nah Breaking Point
it says 2013 on here 2012. I think 2011
because that's so look 2011 it says here
Emilia Rose Breaking Point produced by
Jake 2011. so that means the the record
because that was when everything wasn't
project like we would run singles before
projects right it wasn't like a post
campaign okay so yeah it was about 10
years ago let's just say 10. We'll
average it to 10. a cool decade a cool
you know little dime was that your that
was your first or that was your first I
think second that was your second okay
because maybe it was this it was the
first one that um that people cared
about that I had like
came to you for because I remember
finding you through my boy uh Slim in
Phoenix you did a drop for him once for
me shout out to dearly departed clothing
um but yeah shout out to you man